ah one more if I get it
oh I'm okay I thought I wasn't gonna
make that one oh boy now I get to go on
a nice little ramp no excuse me I need
to get into the secret lab that you guys
are talking about pardon me sir don't
shoot I'm too beautiful to die Oh ninety
six point two five watch me live and
I'll give you my body
yeah I'm ready concentrate
I need your focus here my butt did you
really focus it up my butt with your leg
man you do what you do you get freaky
with yourself quite literally in fact
this table under your balls or anima
wait no rug
I ain't afraid of you cuz that killed
myself that's why that's all you get
thank you hey that counts it counts it
got me wins I think that I will not have
a problem with I'm bad down you couldn't
wait a bit Curtis what my titties this
isn't my sleigh what happened last night
the chattering too much eggnog okay ran
from nice little car you better hope
bids you don't stay there for a bit
because it's gonna get very dangerous
very quickly you watch out as well this
is a very dangerous stop humping each
other and get scared cuz this is gonna
get crazy this is obviously a Porsche
911 Turbo I've been watching my top gear
this is the Porsche 911 Turbo no come on
something besides just instant death
would be delightful
maybe if I'm happy and positive about it
I can make it well those are all my
buffers okay
breaking balls for the first time in my
life I can't handle this many balls come
on get the last target yep yeah
where is this j3d obstacle course I
didn't even get two steps back I mean no
my son
Kevon I don't need my daddy to tell me
what to do he's such a douchebag
he'll always tell me what to do always
don't it ow didn't know how gross oh
yeah oh that's disgusting
oh I hate this as I keep playing this
flip no no no there we go God oh my
goodness this would be a magical
adventure if I wasn't humping this
turtle and I'm not moving so I guess
this is my life now
you stop that it's unnatural okay all
right you could come with me my love
we're going on a magical adventure
landmine landmine this is impossible
impossible
keep going son dead don't matter still
alive don't matter whoa
this isn't right this doesn't feel
natural it's really very wrong I was
looking at you and not on the screen oh
you when I should have been looking at
there I'm looking at you again I know
you're all very beautiful and lovely
people but I gotta concentrate on this
huh get away this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye